right a
iceland inspired beautiful scrambled egg
with an amazing smoked salmon but it's a
hot smoked salmon here i've got some
beautiful little uh
mystique chips okay i'm gonna spread
them over the coals
okay and look let me just sit over there
tuck them in that's gonna give it a
really nice smokey flavor
now literally in fact that wind is
actually quite good because it sort of
helps stokes the fire
and that must be gives that lovely
flavor and the salmon
i'm going to tilt over the flame so it's
like a hot
smoked salmon beautiful way of cooking
salmon
but the thing behind this salmon is this
beautiful
arctic time so this time it's so strong
i've rubbed the salmon with the salt
and the thyme and sort of let it
marinate for about 35 40 minutes
the salt extracts all that water out of
the salmon and then starts to
impose this amazing flavor there so hot
smoked
now the actual scrambled egg again
beautifully done
eggs into a bowl now
i'm gonna do four eggs okay again no
salt just a touch
of butter okay get everything ready
first
oh some beautiful chives if i chop them
now to blow away
so chop the chives as you need them now
from there take your spatula get your
creme fresh ready
now over we go eggs on
into the middle like with the rain
here's the rain now give that a really
good mix
let that butter melt let the pan do the
work
onto the heat 30 seconds bring it back
off
beautiful and then from there look
so good the butter's melting is going to
give it that nice creaminess
keep on mixing really important that we
mix get that nice even distribution
of the butter through the eggs now
it's starting to roll beautiful
and the salmon you can see it's sizzing
away
it's so nice we've got salmon on here
you could have a bass on there you could
put cod on there
you could literally hot smoke majority
of the fish
so much easier when the fish is oily
back on into the center of the heat now
i'm going to start the seasoning
just to touch that salt
with the icelandic thyme pepper
and then back off again lift it up
beautiful now she's coming together
so good back on the center
i'm going to start lifting up this pull
this back
it doesn't get too hot yeah beautiful
that's cooking beautifully back over
and look that's where you want the
scrambled eggs now it's coming together
take that off and then literally a
tablespoon
of crumb fresh in okay
get your chives and then just chop
the chives give that really nice light
sort of onion flavor
okay and because
we're using that incredible hot smoked
salmon
some lemon zest okay
look at that that lightens the load of
the scrambled egg
and then next to that i've got this
little beautiful dill
i rubbed the salmon as well just chop
that once
nice and rough quick so it doesn't blow
away
and then literally fold that into the
scrambled eggs now
that is beautiful from there
correct the seasoning and then
that lemon so delicious
it's so beautiful scrambled egg
on the side that lemon literally
lifts up that flavor beautifully and now
for the
real inspiration wait to see this fish
when it comes off so beautiful look at
that
beautiful take out my little dowels
now with a salmon just with a
really nice sharp knife slice through
clean
and then look at that it's all nice and
pink
sit that on top
and there you have the most amazing
icelandic hot smoked salmon bottle
potato
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus